[Music]
why don't we go next
we have a little bit of time left and we
could we could talk to some more people
let's go to john from orange county
california what's going on john
hey david can you hear me yes i can
okay um well basically
i just wanted to get your thoughts about
the future of georgia um
in terms of like uh national elections
in the future
because i've i've heard from like sam
cedar
and and and his crew that
these these ideas about if it's going to
become
a battleground state or not and that's
something that i thought
would be an interesting topic to hear
you talk about
yeah we we've addressed this a number of
times uh demographically
there seems to be evidence that points
to georgia being a more reliable
purple state certainly what happened in
2020
joe biden won two of republican
incumbent senators
were unseated by two democratic
challengers
there's every indication that this could
be a
permanent swing state rather than the
mostly reliable red state i think 2022
will give us a little bit of a signal
and then 2024 maybe more of one
right right um and
and sort of i guess a follow-up to that
um
and this and this thing is an
interesting question is why do you think
that change happened
and i know that part of that reason is
probably due to
the trump administration but just um
demographics and voter registration two
things have gone on in georgia
people moving to georgia that are more
left-leaning
and people like stacy abrams and others
getting
left-leaning people who may not be
engaged with the political system
registered and out to vote right
right i see okay
well thank you john i have to ask were
you slapping something while you were
talking to me
no you weren't interested no it was not
interesting
all right john thank you very much for
the call
yeah all right very good uh john from
orange county california all right
everybody that's all the time i have
for calls today i'm sorry i am
sorry i wasn't able to get to everybody
but i will take
calls again one of our longtime
sponsors is vincero watches and i would
love for you to support these guys and
right now for a very limited time during
their
spring upgrade sale you will save
up to 30 off all of their products
vincero
only creates watches that are
exceptionally crafted
with a sleek modern look and they're
sustainably made which i love
i just picked up vincero's chrono
s model in gunmetal and walnut
i love the simple design the high
quality engraving on the face
with the contrast of the dark leather
strap vincero
really does create what i think are
visually beautiful watches
it's springtime it's time to upgrade
your look
freshen up your style and a great
quality watch
like this is the perfect way to do it
they also have sunglasses wallets and
bracelets
which are excellent and for a very
limited time vincero's
spring upgrade sale is giving you up to
30
off all of their products just go to
vincerocollective.com
david the link is right underneath this
video